in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Stephan
and Julie are with us hey guys how are
y'all
fantastic welcome it's good to have you
where are you from Dallas Texas all
right very cool and here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir how much have
you paid off one hundred and sixty-five
thousand over a total of 32 months cash
flow cash flow to wedding yeah there's
always that good cool so how long you
been married eight months now ah very
good there you go
you better get that straight I'll just
go ahead and give you a little husband
hint right now you're gonna want to know
that going forward so what's your
household income so when we I started
paying it off by myself it about sixty
four thousand plus a lot of odd jobs and
then now we are over two hundred
thousand together excellent okay very
cool man you knocked out a bunch now
what'd you say the total debt payoff was
so our total debt paid off was about
165,000 um when I started I paid off
twenty five thousand and six months met
him he laid off his car so about 45,000
that summer we cash flowed a wedding for
a year and then ninety ninety thousand
in about eight months alright recently
very cool good for you guys
very well done so really really so so
you kind of started this whole thing
Julie it sounds like yeah alright and so
Steven you're dating this girl and she's
cute but she's a little money crazy got
all these crazy ideas right it was
actually really interesting the first
time I met her I was walking her back to
my car which was a Corvette and she
stopped gave me a crazy look and said
really you know you're in this car
supposed to be a chick magnet and it's
got the opposite of fact exactly I did I
told him I think on the second date now
I was so condescending I said you know
I'm on the Dave Ramsey plan and that
summer he paid it off he got his bonus
he cleared out his savings that was gone
very good this is this is legitimate
person and all right that's good I like
a skepticism that's good that's good
that's good very cool
so hey I've got the red one too yeah
that's a great car man
I love it it's a correct car it's a
beast it is so fun to drive way to go
man very cool what do y'all do for a
living I'm a physician and she's an
attorney okay very cool
well great careers and you're 100% debt
free and man you got you guys got a
future is incredible so Julie how did
you first get introduced to all of this
so you actually came to speak for pastor
Craig at Life Church when I lived in
Norman you know years ago and I was Kris
I meant paying attention I was still
really entrenched in a lot of ignorance
about finances just my childhood was
steeped in financial instability and I
think oftentimes when you get in these
these situations even if there's a
healthy influence like a grandparent
who's frugal when you're under the
poverty line
or income you don't discuss it with
children right and so I mean I'm in oh
you and I thought Law School is and I
got my masters after that like education
is the escape my circumstances that's
the way out and and it wasn't it was it
was debt and I
what isn't saved me from anything that
was 2008 there was the housing crash and
my fiancee called off her wedding a few
days before and I had taken out
significant you know tens of thousands
extra to pay for that I was never paid
back for it and so I found myself in my
early 20s living downtown in a big city
I didn't have a family that could
financially help me and I was $100,000
in debt and I was so scared and I was I
was depressed all the time everything
was a crisis and just by Providence I
remembered I thought like I needed to
change anything and I remembered at you
and so I googled the podcast and I I
absorbed him and I remember it's ironic
but you told me it was my fault if it
was the most hope I'd ever had because
if you can associate that your situation
is indicative of previous poor decision
then your you can alter your behavior
for a different outcome and that's so
hopeful because I wasn't a victim
anymore so I paid off 25,000 in six
months I mean I got all these extra odd
jobs and then I meet this guy and you
know he supported me in that and and I
found out you know he comes from this
completely healthy background but I mean
I read
boundaries and I got new role models and
I want to give people permission you
know if you wake up in this situation
where you're coming from
family dysfunction or a broken home it's
so easy to think you know oh I worked
through all this stuff or you go get an
advanced degree or a doctor and you
think well now I live in a skyrise and
I'm an uptown and I'm young and I went
through all that so I want to pay for
things to make myself happy but that's
not the answer and when I when my
perspective changed that god has blessed
me with my intellect and my income for a
purpose mm-hmm this isn't to play with
or waste is to help others and it just
changed everything I was so motivated
and you know I remember the whole time I
was growing up for years my father died
- yeah he was sick when I was young and
my grandpa died and I have wishing
somebody would come some rich person
would come rescue me and and do all
these things I would have had these
daydreams about them buying me a car and
it never happened but I know now God
gave me that so that when I was older I
could be a philanthropist and I could
help others and I can't tell you the
difference I mean already like we paid
off her debt what a month like I already
did a pro bono case for a lady a friend
died without life insurance and so I
just did the probate like I could just
anytime I want to help like I'm not tied
to have to work for a certain job and we
already helped us some single mom
friends with some stuff I mean it's like
anywhere I see a need I am just
overwhelmed with gratitude and I think
there was a time and I think you've
discussed this very vividly there was a
time when I only focused on myself
because my entire life was about
mitigating pain and for people who
suffer depression and anxiety and in bad
situations that feeling is real but you
don't have to be a helpless as soon as
you make a conscious decision it's in
front of you and now my whole life is
full of gratitude and my only reasonable
response is like pastor Craig says
irrational generosity mm-hmm and I just
once I'm I'm so overwhelmed like I want
to make God and my dad and my
grandfather proud and and help people
and everything that has gone before is
just leading up to this and I'm so
blessed with this husband you know I
think I think there's a lot about debt
payoff and I wanted to mention this with
forgiveness I hesitated to bring up some
of this negative stuff the wedding being
called off
we also had somebody very close to us at
the very end of this and get ready
because if you do the debt payoff God
may work on your heart in a very
challenging way and we have somebody
very close to us do something incredibly
unethical and cost us tens of thousands
and there's so much is it's very
difficult to face injustice that's a
difficult lesson but we had peace and
choices about how to respond and try to
remedy that and and we thought even if
we were never compensated you can let go
whether it's your family not making good
decisions that hurt you and you were
getting started in life or being left at
the altar or you know financial betrayal
from somebody you can let that stuff go
when the debt is in the past you're on a
victim anymore and you're just stronger
and you think you know that's you know
where promise troubles in this life like
I'm I have to send this video to Craig
he and I are good friends he's gonna
love this I also think if I need
something litigated in Dallas I know who
to call you just prosecuted the case I'm
telling you I'm very well done you and
he were a huge help in this journey and
God put it in front of me but I and just
like I like you I want to be others you
guys are heroes I'm so proud of you you
really have done I mean what you
recognized there that that your choices
that I'm not as articulate it took me
twenty nine years and you know but you
saw what you said a minute ago was that
once you recognize that your choices can
change then now you're in control of
your life that's so empowering and that
I can decide today to do this or not do
this and that suddenly I can turn this
around and and then you did it you guys
are heroes I don't want to give credit
to my husband because here he is working
very difficult hours and in you know
poor guy wakes up at 5 in the morning
some days for surgery and I he's paying
off my mistakes from the past and he's
tired hey he got a deal it's ok
165 thousand dollars paid off in 32
months we're gonna give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's retire inspired book as
well making 64 up to 200
oh what a great great debt-free scream
Stephan and Julie from Dallas Texas
counted down let's hear it
three two well done this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common